on vient du monde entier pour ce silence
pour voir le chef-d'oeuvre de le
corbusier la chapelle notre dame du haut
à ronchamp on avait demandé à le
corbusier de construire ici une chapelle
intime dans laquelle on puisse venir se
recueillir prier en silence mais on lui
avait aussi demandé de construire une
chapelle qui puisse accueillir les
nombreux pèlerins qui venaient ici deux
fois par an le 8 septembre et le 15 ou
et les visites guidées finissent
désormais toujours par l'oratoire du
monastère dessiné par un autre grand
architecte renzo piano
sinclair qui a été construit il ya juste
dix ans
et donc nous fêtons ce premier
anniversaire
ces jours ci et pourquoi vous connaissez
sûrement la chapelle mais il fallait un
complément qui est important d'une part
pour l'accueil des visiteurs avec la
porterie mais aussi pour la prière
permanente et l'accueil spirituel des
personnes qui ont le
désir de s'arrêter de se poser
cette histoire n'était pas écrite
d'avancé
en 2006 les clarisses décident de
quitter leur vieux monastère de besançon
pour fonder une communauté
internationale à ronchamp
souffrance et tout ça alors prête à
quitter là ça me gêne pas du tout je
suis pas attaché au lieu
de ça coûte beaucoup voir
ça ne me choque pas mais enfin sur la
communauté
elles ont voté pour le projet parce
qu'elle semble bien que c'est un projet
de vie et ça ça leur rapporte pas ce que
tu as projet dit pour l'ordre s'est pas
uniquement pour nous un projet dit pour
l'ordre pour l'ordre des clarisses en
france en tous les cas car c'est le seul
projet qui soit porteur de d'une
nouveauté
les soeurs ne se doutait pas des
obstacles qu'elle allait devoir franchir
en 2008 la baisse soeur brigitte seront
en italie à assise le berceau de la
famille franciscaine les clarisses du
monde entier sont réunis une occasion
unique pour présenter le projet des
soeurs de besançon donc la communauté de
valence on va fermer pour créer une
fraternité internationale capable
d'accueillir le des entretiens ou des
petits séjours d autres pouvant arriver
les cinq continents
respecting bébé
et un mode défi
c'est très difficile d'intégrer les
cultures et ça c'est vrai mais ce droit
justement j'ai parlé de rencontre et non
pas d'intégration et puis ça forme une
trousse notre clôture
quelque chose de nouveau
c'est l'association propriétaire de la
colline qui a demandé à renzo piano de
construire le monastère et le nouvel
accueil eux aussi vont affronter des
difficultés projet contesté chantier
retardé problèmes de financement mais
l'utopie créatrice est en marche c'est
donc le jardin d'hiver de rang pour
assortir assiège et c'est là qu'on
prouvera les camélias et les citronniers
et puis la seconde phase à
l'inauguration du monastère aura
finalement lieu en septembre 2011
je voudrais rappeler qu'on a travaillé
plus de six ans sur ce projet
qui n'est pas tout à fait achevée mais
presque dix ans plus tard le temps a
fait son oeuvre sur les murs de ciment
deux des soeurs de besançon sont
décédées et quatre nouvelles clarisse
sont venus rejoindre la communauté
on fête les 10 ans d'un chantier de
construction
de murs
maintenant on en est à la construction
d'une fraternité avec neuf soeurs quatre
nationalités six lieux de formation
initiale différents donc on est une
super belle la famille recomposée
et le projet c'est d'être tout de
ronchamp des cons champenoise même si on
vient d'horizons différents
[Musique]